como parte de un esfuerzo nacional de
ahorro en medio de la actual crisis
energética la capital alemana berlín
anunció que dejará de iluminar unos 200
monumentos y edificios públicos entre
ellos algunos de los emblemas más
conocidos de alemania a esta iniciativa
también se han sumado otras ciudades del
país como hannover en el norte que
explicó planes para restringir el uso de
agua caliente en edificios públicos o
munich en el sur que además anunció que
apagará las fuentes públicas otras
medidas anunciadas incluyen revisar la
temperatura de las piscinas públicas o
mirar que semáforos pueden apagarse y no
se trata solamente de las ciudades a los
ciudadanos también se les está pidiendo
que ahorren lo más posible que revisen
sus rutinas energéticas que miren en sus
lugares donde pueden ahorrar energía no
se trata solamente de este esfuerzo
común sino también porque se espera que
los hogares alemanes deban pagar cientos
sino miles de euros adicionales por
cuenta de los altos precios energéticos
y todo esto tiene que ver con la
decisión rusa de reducir aún más el
suministro de gas que llega alemania a
través del gasoducto nord stream 1
alemania es particularmente vulnerable
pues importa alrededor de un tercio de
su gas de rusia